you have these women that have no
emotional regulation and I and you ask
why well we have this society that puts
them on a freaking pedestal and says
they're so amazing and special and
awesome even I don't even guys I don't
even like this propaganda they throw
saying that the most selfless job in the
world is being a housewife really that's
the most selfless job in the world I
mean guys you get to stay at home women
Housewives today have easier lives than
most people have in all of history it is
not this crazy hard job if it was you
wouldn't pay a babysitter $15 an hour to
watch your kids now I'm not discounting
the value of it I think women should
stay home with their children but what
I'm discounting is you guys' freaking
female narcissism left and right it
drives me freaking crazy and then I'm
the bad guy for pointing out no no
that's not true because I I don't go
with the Pander so many of you guys
Pander to your wives you Pander to your
girlfriends and I'm just sick of seeing
it because this is what you get this is
what pandering gives you and then you're
going to get in these crazy situations
and you wonder why they're you're in
them